Can you believe it's only been six months since your last performance review?
Wow!
Where to begin?
I guess, let's start at the top.
Your hair is disgusting.
Everybody can tell you're using a shampoo conditioner combo.
Moving down the skull, you're starting to get bags under your eyes like Jake,...
...and it's making it harder to tell you apart.
On a positive note, you are not a fraud,...
...but that's only because you failed to fool anyone...
...into thinking you are remotely competent.
Your knees are knobby as all hell, just two big, horrifying knobs.
I'd turn them, but I'm afraid what lurks behind those doors.
I'll skip your splinty shins for now, but we both know your toes are weird.
And last but not least,...
...we know from our screen monitoring program you've been watching movies at work.
And you have terrible taste.
In summation, your job is hanging by a thread, and you're living in a scissors factory.
Well, John, some of those adjectives will haunt me for the rest of my life.
Right.
You clearly put a lot of thought into that, so good job.
Sorry, you're telling me that I did a good job on your performance review?
Yeah?
Great. Thank you, Matt.
I did do a good job.
And hey, all that stuff about your job hanging by a thread,...
...you know I'm just trying to motivate you, right?
I mean, if the lion tamer doesn't crack the whip,...
...the lions start thinking he doesn't have a whip.
You catch my drift?
I don't know if you've ever seen lions turn on their master,...
...but there's a reason that I'd stopped watching lion videos.
That's a really effective analogy, John.
Good job.
Great.